All right.
Gary, Eduardo,
congratulations, guys.
Your hard work has
paid off, and it
is now down to the two
of you battling it out
for the title of
"Forged in Fire"
Champion and that
check for $10 grand.
And because this
competition's all
about iconic weapons
from South America,
we're sticking with that theme.
We're giving you four
days to build this--
the Argentinean saber.
[music playing]
DAVID BAKER: The Argentinean
saber was a fierce 19th century
weapon used by the
cavalry soldiers known
as the Argentinean Grenadiers.
These mounted warriors used the
lightweight single-edged blade
to deliver swift
and lethal slashes
against enemies, while the large
hilt protected their hands.
After their crucial service
in the Argentinian War
of Independence,
the Grenadiers were
given the honor of becoming
the presidential escort guard.
Today, these elite
soldiers still
protect the president with this
powerful saber at their sides.
All right, guys.
We will see you in four days.
- Good luck.
- We got this.
Stay safe, dude.
[music playing]
EDUARDO: My name's Eduardo Sol.
I am originally from Mexico.
I moved to the US because
I was a foreign exchange
student during college and
met the woman of my dreams.
And she got me
into blacksmithing.
And I got hooked on knives.
My concern is that
pipeback spine.
Here we go.
I never knew that
existed until today.
The biggest challenge
is putting in the curve
that's the requirement
while still keeping
the pipeback spine intact.
Forging is going really well.
It's good enough,
it's close enough,
and I am ready for the quench.
Ooh.
The blade is hard, the blade is
straight, and I am exhausted.
All I need to do now is
get started on my hilt.
One of the parameters
is drilling
the piercings in the hilt.
There's that disk.
These rotary disks are
literally exploding
as soon as I put them on.
The guard is too hard for the
rotor disks to cook through.
[groans]
This one line right there took
two and a half cutting disks.
I am extremely
aggravated by this.
This is supposed to
be quick and easy.
I am burning through my day.
I'm falling behind.
I hope I'm going to
have enough time.
All righty, now to
make that pretty.
I finally finish the
piercings on my guard.
I am down to a single
rotary disk left.
[laughs] But I'm
running out of time.
I need to fly through my handle.
Hopefully, everything's
going to marry up perfectly.
That's it.
Overall, I'm still on schedule.
After I peen this
on and close it,
I'm going to grind
this extra steel off
so it's a much tighter
fit to the handle.
It's time to peen the guard
and then sharpen my blade.
That should be it.
It's really coming out great.
That is sharp.
[music playing]
GARY (VOICEOVER): I'm Gary
Graham from Elkmont, Alabama.
12 days after I turned 18,
I enlisted in the Army,
flying UH-60 Black Hawks.
Started making my first
blade after I got home
from deployment, and
it continued to grow
to a small business now.
I forged the blade out, got
the length I want out of it,
got it forced to shape,
drawing it out with my dies
and verifying that
everything's nice and even.
It's looking good.
It's time to go and
sharpen the blade.
So I'm at the point now
I'm going to go out and do
some testing with my blade.
Whoops.
Missed part of it.
I bent my blade.
I come out with a blade
looking like a boomerang.
Damn.
I only got one more
day to get it done.
There's no time to waste.
I've got to get working
on a new blade immediately
and make this one work.
We should have the
process down pat now.
We're good on parameters.
It's been a hell of a
day, but at the end,
I've got a quenched blade.
This blade looks a lot
better than the blade
that didn't work out so great.
It's time for me to work
on my hand and my hilt.
I grab a piece of sheet metal,
cut out the shape that I want,
and I start shaping
it in the swage block.
Now, I'm going to cut these
piercings in in my hilt.
My plan to put this handle
together to secure it properly
is I want to notch out my
tang, weld in a machine boat
with a spacer so I
can tighten it all up.
And the last thing I
need to do is sharpen it
and assemble the sword.
That's it for Round 3.
It's in the judges' hands now.
All right, bladesmiths,
welcome to the kill test.
Well, it's time to find out just
how lethal your weapons are.
I'm going to take your
weapons and deliver
some thrusts and slashes
on this pig carcass.
Gary, you're up first.
You ready for this?
I'm ready.
Let's do this.
GARY (VOICEOVER):
Since I've already
warped one blade
during testing at home,
I'm nervous as a cat
on a hot tin roof.
I don't want my blade to
crack, I don't want it to warp,
and I don't want it to break.
[music playing]
DOUG MARCAIDA: All
right, Gary, let's talk
about your weapon here.
First up, most of the weight
is right in the very tip
of this blade.
But the saving grace for
that is that you have a nice
handle right there where
I can grab onto it,
I can marry my
hand, it's a void,
and I've got full
control with this weapon.
As you can see, those
were very deep cuts.
Overall, sir, your weapon--
it will kill.
Thank you.
All right, Eduardo,
your turn, sir.
Are you ready?
- I'm excited.
Let's go.
Let's do this.
EDUARDO (VOICEOVER): I
know my edge is fantastic.
It can take a beating.
It's a killer blade.
I can't wait to
see what it can do.
[sighs]
[music playing]
Gentlemen, I think
we have a problem here.
That's a very small handle.
My hand barely fits in there.
And when I'm swinging,
there was just
no retention or stop right
here, especially in the slashes.
For thrusting it with
a forward weight,
all that is on my wrist.
What do you think?
BEN ABBOTT: Oh, I see
what you're saying.
I could swing it now.
DOUG MARCAIDA: But swinging--
But I can't pull
it back up because I
don't have the leverage.
Yeah, I'm looking at
my fingers double up.
The problem is, is
there's no space in there.
If it does cut loose,
that's breaking my hand.
Is there any way to
adjust and make it fair?
The problem with
that is I can hold back
to make it work, but
now I'm holding back,
and that's not an
even test anymore.
OK.
You guys all agree, the
blade's not safe to wield?
Yes.
BEN ABBOTT: Definitely.
GRADY POWELL: OK.
[bleep]
Eduardo, we
absolutely hate to see
a competition end like this.
But when wielding
an edged weapon,
safety is always of
the utmost importance.
Due to the small
handle you've presented
and the lack of
retention that it offers,
the judges have issued
a vote of no confidence.
They can't safely
test your weapon.
So unfortunately, your time
in this competition has ended.
I'm going to have
to ask you to please
step off the "Forged" floor.
It's all right.
Congratulations, buddy.
Thanks.
Thank you though, Eduardo.
I'm crushed.
I'm disappointed.
I worked really hard for
it not to get tested.
It fit my hand perfectly.
Every step of this competition
was a learning experience.
And I really think I'm
leaving a better smith.
Gary, you are today's
"Forged in Fire" Champion.
You got yourself a
check for $10,000.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
It feels great to be the
"Forged in Fire" Champion.
What are you going to
do with the $10 grand?
Do you have plans?
- No, I'm sure my wife does.
[laughter]
GARY (VOICEOVER): I just want
to savor this for a while.
There was a lot
of work to get here.
It's been fun, I've met
a lot of great people,
and I've enjoyed it.
[music playing]